bonsoir sont arrosés d'eau merci d'être
avec nous quand on voit ce qui compte ce
clip on comprend que les années si dans
les années 90 ont porté leurs fruits
manifestement à cuba en termes d'
expertise
bonsoir alors effectivement enfin il ya
une tradition du développement de la
santé à cuba qui est extrêmement
ancienne et au delà de l' expertise
autour du sida c'est un secteur que cuba
a investi et qui est l'un des plus
performants de son économie bien avant
vous mentionnez donc bien avant y
compris les années 90 vous mentionner
les brigades que ben on voit aux quatre
coins du monde il faut bien comprendre
que au delà de cette aide que ça peut
apporter un semblant de vie dans le
monde c'est aussi une source de devises
pour l'état cubain et que c'est l'une de
ses principales sources de devises donc
c'est vraiment un secteur la santé que
cuba a investi et dans lequel il a un
avantage comparatif pour reprendre les
termes économiques par rapport à la
plupart des pays de la planète y compris
les pays les plus développés alors
et pourtant et pourtant alors on
aimerait bien être à leur place je ne
dis pas le contraire mais pourtant le
vaccin n'est toujours pas prêt en tout
cas mais n'est toujours pas injecter
comment ça se fait expliquer nous alors
il n'est pas encore en injecter mis en
phase de test donc vous ne mentionnez
dans votre introduction les vaccins se
balade à dos et abdallah sont phase iii
il ya trois autres copains vaccins
candidats qui sont en face un petit peu
en petit barrière
faut bien comprendre que pour un pays
latino américains c'est une performance
déjà d'être d'être dans deux niveaux en
phase 3 il ya aussi des difficultés de
tests liés aux mesures coercitives
prises par les états unis qui les
détestent qu'on était fait la phase de
test qui a été fait en iran parce que
mais du coup c'est difficile de faire
des tests dans une mairie qui a été
assez peu touché en fait par là par le
virus et toute cette situation
géopolitique extrêmement complexe et
extrêmement contrainte dans laquelle se
retrouvent cuba un poste d'aidé compte
des contraintes supplémentaires pour
pour les biologistes pour pour espérer
monter ce vaccin alors le pays aussi été
durement touchée par la crise économique
on le fait avec quelles ressources
arrive-t-il à produire ce vaccin quand
le kobus qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
qu elle le fait par un effort
volontarisme politique depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies si on l'expliquent
uniquement par des ressources
économiques fin à une cuba devrait avoir
une médecine bien moins performante que
celle qu'elle a aujourd'hui il ya une
crise économique qui est
particulièrement froid parce qu'une des
autres sources de devises importantes de
cuba c'est le tourisme et on le sait le
tourisme est l'un des secteurs les plus
impactés par la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui il ya eu une volonté de
d'accélérer des réformes de restauration
de l'économie de marché à la fin de
l'année dernière et au début de cette
année qui au vu de cette crise
économique ne portent pas leurs fruits
dit fait que nombreux cubains qui en
sait s'investir dans des activités
privées demandent l'aide à l'état et
demande à se réengager par l'état parce
que on est dans une situation économique
ou pas le secteur privé ne prospère pas
précisément parce que
des dépendances au tourisme aujourd'hui
une particulière faiblesse de l'économie
cubaine en ces temps de crise sanitaire
que va t-il les moyens de produire et
vendre donc ces vaccins aux autres pays
d'amérique latine
alors je pense qu'ils vont le faire
enfin le ski est ce qui a été dit c'est
qu'ils vont fournir en particulier aux
pays les plus pauvres et je pense pas
qu'ils aient une dimension de vente de
ce point de vue là et qui vont prioriser
les pays qui n'ont pas eu accès au
vaccin
pour l'instant les mécanismes pour pour
les billets les plus pauvres d'avoir
accès aux vaccins scénique ennemi kovacs
donc liée à l' oms et qui distribue en
fait assez peu de vaccins enfin du moins
en nombre insuffisant pour protéger de
manière substantielle la population pour
pour cela il ya des partenaires
diplomatique de cuba qui est à vendre
des vaccins notamment le venezuela qui
ont déjà reçu quelques fournitures de
tests de sauver la noce sur leur
territoire et on en est à ce point de
vue là je pourrai pas vous répondre
précisément sur le paiement de ces
vaccins mais je sais qu'il ya une
priorité qui a été donné sur sur les
pays les plus pauvres qui n'ont pas eu
accès aux réservations pour les
principaux bassins les plus les plus
reconnus aujourd'hui un haut niveau
mondial est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
l'arrivée de ce vaccin cubain puisse
accroître l'influencé de cuba en
amérique latine si je pense le pari du
gouvernement cubain
et de fait oui c'est qu'elle a un pari
qui marche
simple et qui marche depuis plusieurs
décennies cuba arrive à obtenir des
victoires diplomatiques à l'onu à
l'unesco que
ce qui met souvent en rage les états
unis mais qui sont sans doute le fin qui
sont en grande partie le fruit de ce
volontarisme médical de de cette
politique internationale sur ce biais là
et qui qui permet d'avoir une île de 11
millions d'habitants un poids
géopolitique qui qui est nettement
surdimensionné à ces dispositions et
démographique et économique pose est
docteur en sciences politiques d'avoir
été avec nous en direct assure rt france